multi-day bike trips have always been
tough in the United States just by the
sheer volume of gear that you have to
carry tent sleeping bag food and water
except in the southwest corner of
Colorado where there's a series of huts
each one placed about one day's ride
apart in 1987 the San Juan hunt system
was launched and in 2004 they put in a
new roof from Durango Colorado to Moab
Utah from my buddy Jay and me it's 250
miles seven days from these mountains to
Red Rock Country
the beauty of the Ceylon hunt system is
this baby right here without it there is
no way you can ride from Durango to Moab
250 miles with nothing on your back put
extra clothes inside for sleeping bags
bunks the food oh man the food
floor-to-ceiling cabinets with a hungry
mouth bikers 3
of the to San Juan Hut roots the Durango
to Moab is more challenging with 26,000
feet of climbing but the payoff 115
miles of singletrack
almost 50% of the route by the time you
get to Moab you've crossed the San Juan
Mountains the huge Dry Creek Basin 3
mesas and finally the LaSalle mountains
you've earned a sense the Colorado
Plateau from the saddle up and even
better a well-earned sense of
accomplishment but then what might be
the best part of the whole ride you
finished on one of the world's best
single tracks the porcupine rim trail
which brings you into Moab at long last
this is one physical adventure that
rewards you with one of the most
spectacular landscapes in America
you